let's go next to kevin from uh virginia
kevin from virginia you're on the air
hello david hello
i realize this is kind of
old news at this point but i've been
trying to call in the last couple of
weeks i want to talk about permanent
daylight saving time okay
i am on on the side of permanent
standard time
i could go on a diatribe of i i
personally think it's better but i think
my best argument on the subjects is more
of a historical one
so my framing of this issue is
if if we are going to go to permanent
daylight saving time what we're really
doing is we're changing our time zones
by one time zone
and you're kind of saying
if you want to go to permanent daylight
saving time you're saying we got it
wrong
when we established
the time zones in the late 1800s or you
think society has changed fundamentally
in that last 150 or so years that we all
benefit from shifting our schedules by
one hour sure and i just don't think
that's i don't think that's accurate i
think
there was a lot of thought put into the
time zones when they were established
and it lined up with
solar time that we used for
millennia
i don't think we should change that
so listen i think that actually society
has changed dramatically since the time
zones were established by virtue of
completely ubiquitous electricity and
artificial lighting i think i think that
it has changed now that's not reason
alone to say let's do permanent daylight
saving now i lean towards permanent
daylight saving you know why because i
don't get up early enough to care about
it being dark in the morning and i get a
lot of benefit from it being light out
an additional hour in winter in the
northeast
in middle of december it's it's ugly
it's depressing what goes on in the
northeast now that being said
i am sensitive to the fact that you know
if you look at the western edge of
certain time zones like for example if
you look at columbus ohio is an
interesting place
in columbus ohio they're on the western
edge of the eastern time zone
if we were to do permanent daylight
saving time if i understand correctly in
december sunrise would be something like
8 20 in columbus i looked it up at one
point i don't exactly remember i agree
that that's kind of complicated that's
not so good so another idea i heard was
split the difference make a 30 minute
adjustment and make that permanent the
problem is that then the difference
between our time zones and those in
other parts of the world are going to be
you know six and a half hours eight and
a half hours which is just very
complicated so i don't know that there's
a perfect solution
i hate what we do now and i lean towards
permanent daylight saving time
i also hate what we do now yeah um i
personally i think we need to be taking
a hard look at
schedule of the business day the
schedule of schools you know there's
been a lot written about
um school starting too early and and the
health impacts that has on our children
i feel like
going with permanent daylight saving
time we're kind of sidestepping
the real issue but yeah
also which is there are other countries
where it's much much more typical that
the the business and work day starts at
either 9 30 or 10 and goes to more like
six or seven and then like in a lot of
places in europe you leave work at seven
and then you know you go right to drinks
and then a later dinner like when i was
in spain now spain maintains the siesta
for a lot of workers
you open the store at ten and then
you're off from one to three and then
you're open from three to seven and at
seven you go for a drink and at 9 30 you
have dinner and it's just a totally
different lifestyle now culturally i
don't know that that'll work in the u.s
but there's many other configurations of
the daily schedule that could work
well i appreciate you talking to me
about this i'll be curious to see if if
it does get enacted permanently yeah do
you still like it after your first
winter going through it because right
now
we know what standard time is like in
the winter and we have some issues with
that but
unless we can remember back to 1974 we
don't really know what the mornings are
like in a winter with dst and i think
people are i'll sleep through it so i
just won't know i mean i'll be fine
all right all right kevin thank you uh i
i i do care about that topic actually i
find it pretty pretty interesting
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual
payment cards with one click and when i
use the virtual card the money is taken
out of my bank account you can create
multiple cards delete them freeze them
set a spending limit on them let's say
i'm signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up i can delete that
virtual card so i know i'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video